and more than 90 days after president
biden tapped her as the point person on
immigration vice president kamala harris
will finally make her first visit to the
border tomorrow
critics point out that harris is going
to el paso more than 800 miles from
towns like mcallen
which is seeing the basically the
epicenter of the crisis here's senator
ted cruz
to give you a sense of just how far they
are
chicago illinois is closer to washington
d.c
than el paso is to mcallen and so she's
going where the where the height of the
problem isn't commonly you need to go to
mcallen
kamala you need to go to the donna tent
facility you need to look at the
children in cages
that you and joe biden put there in a
way that is endangering their safety
let's bring in congressman henry cuellar
a democrat from texas and you've been
keeping us informed about what's going
on down there the entire time
you just recent i think you believe us
yesterday had a joint op-ed with cornyn
and gonzalez
in the dallas morning news asking the
vice president or the biden
administration to come and visit
uh do you think that this is a good step
that she's going and are you
disappointed that it's going to be in el
paso
you know first of all i'm glad that
she's going down to the border
because that is part of her job
portfolio number one
and number two um yes the epicenter is
down there
in the lower rio grande lower part of my
district down there if you look at the
numbers that are down there compared to
el paso
you're not going to get a a true picture
of what's happening
you go to the donna facility you go to
roma texas you go to
rio grande city you go to the mcallen
area so you can get an
idea that's how you can get an idea of
of what's happening you're right about
that so
so if that's the case why go
well uh again she's going down to the
border she'll say she'll go down to the
border
uh yesterday i got a um a call from one
of my border patrol friends and said hey
why is she going over there we got about
140 percent
higher crossings over here this is where
the activity is
at and i couldn't answer him when he
asked me that question
he's down there in the low rio grande so
even if she goes to el paso which is a
first step
she's got to spend time with landowners
with the stakeholders with cities the
counties
officials and i hope she sits down with
our brave
men and women in green and in blue our
border patrol agents so they don't just
get a pat in the back
but they actually get some reinforcement
and some support down there yes sir
you have been on our program many times
over the past several months and we
appreciate you coming back today
but you extended an invitation to her
for months
did you ever hear back from her uh no we
didn't uh
we heard about it from the news like
everybody else in fact i talked to
some other uh texas democrats they had
no idea until they saw it in the news so
again
uh it doesn't matter if it's a
democratic republican you've got to pay
courtesy
uh to the members of congress that are
down there at the border
do you think that you might get an
invitation to travel along with her i
mean that usually is customary
well that's not my district and i am an
appropriations
member we already started appropriations
and there are things
i'm already adding to help our border
patrol agents to put things in
uh to work with mexico and central
america so i'm gonna do my job there
where she goes to
el paso about 800 plus miles away from
the
rio grande valley i don't know what
she's going to see there and you you
point a pretty uh pain of pretty uh
vivid picture
for perhaps a trip that may not show her
much
why do you think this administration has
waited so long for this
uh i have no idea but i'm sure her
planners told her that if you're going
to go down to the border
go to a uh something that's safer to go
to that is
politically safer if you go down to the
low rio grande with a high activity and
you're there with kids and families
prosecutorial discretion where people
are being released high numbers of
people crossing the border
uh you know politically that's it's
harder to do that i know that i mean
that's part of my district
but you got to do what you got to do you
just can't uh
you know just go to one place but she
does do the check the box and go down to
the border
by going to it just by the way just to
be clear you're a democratic congressman
from texas you've been pleading for help
and you just talked about a politically
safe trip on behalf of the vice
president
is that how you see it uh yes sir
well you know the thing is that she'll
at least um she'll be able to say that
she went to a border town
the week before president trump is going
to join governor greg abbott
in that same area thank you congressman
cuellar thank you sir we'll talk again
okay
thank you very thank you so much